so many of us have dreamed of getting
romantic with our favorite movie stars
and we all suspect that they have an
incredible time kissing each other on
screen but in reality cinematic history
is full of kissing horror stories
here are a few actors who couldn't stand
kissing their co-stars
there's a serious occupational hazard
when you're kissing somebody in a movie
bad breath many celebrities are in the
infamous bad breath club and a good
example was trying to capture will smith
and ava mendes kissing in the comedy
hitch
mendez was nervous about kissing smith
and she turned to her favorite comfort
foods
tuna fish with lots of onions and
doritos needless to say
smith didn't dig it i saw that
going differently in my mind mendez then
downed a ton of altoids to get rid of
the stank breath special and things went
much more smoothly after that whatever
it took to get through it apparently
worked because an opinion piece on
entertainment weekly recently hailed
hitch as the greatest rom-com of all
time
and smith and mendes also kissed each
other at the film's premiere
hopefully before mendez ate any comfort
food
whoa whoa you right oh no yeah
no no fine speaking of celebrities with
bad breath jennifer lawrence is also a
member of this club the secret got out
when liam hemsworth spilled the beans on
the tonight show starring jimmy fallon
if we had a kissing scene she would make
a point of eating
garlic or tuna fish or you know
something that was disgusting furiously
backpedalling lawrence later responded
i was never like hey liam i just ate
tuna and garlic on purpose
i just would happen to eat something i
didn't change the way i was eating for
the kissing which is different than
eating something on purpose
is it worse she added that if she was
kissing christian bale or bradley cooper
she would definitely brush her teeth
apparently hemsworth didn't make the cut
but the tables were turned when j-law
had a kissing scene with another big
star
bradley cooper received bad marks in the
kissing department from jennifer
lawrence while promoting the third
hangover film cooper confessed to graham
norton that during the production of
silver linings playbook lawrence told
him he was a wet kisser cooper candidly
admitted you don't want to hear that
it was not a compliment and given that
lawrence gets bad notices from her
co-stars for her own smooching skills
that's really gotta hurt
the real irony of this cooper and
lawrence were nominated for the best
kiss at the mtv
awards proving that a-list actors are
more skilled than you realize at
convincing us that they're having a wild
passionate time on screen
when nothing could be further from the
truth an interview with the vampire
kirsten dunst got to kiss brad pitt
right as he was becoming one of the most
desired men in america and she got paid
to do it but she didn't like the
experience at all and reportedly didn't
kiss a boy again for another five years
dunst was 11 at the time i hated it so
much because i don't know brad was like
my older brother on the sentence kind of
like kissing your brother i don't know
years after the fact dunn stood by her
quote and her initial impression that
kissing pit was gross
although i thought it was disgusting it
was like
i was 11 it would have been weird if i
was like this is amazing i'm chasing
brad pitt
it's not easy to build up romance on the
set of a superhero film
in the 2002 version of spider-man
kirsten dunst had to kiss toby maguire
as he was hanging upside down
except this was happening in the rain as
director sam raimi recalled when he was
doing the scene i remember the water was
falling down
into his upside down nostrils so he was
kind of drowning but it was a kissing
scene so he had to pretend like it was a
pleasant sweet moment for him when in
fact he was semi drowning
maguire himself remembered i couldn't
breathe and i was gasping for breath out
of the corner of kirsten's mouth
poor girl i was giving her
mouth-to-mouth rather than kissing her
but in the midst of that i was sneaking
some pleasure out of it
kissing on screen is awkward enough but
it's especially awkward when you have to
do it in front of family or with a close
friend
many have wondered if there was any
real-life romance between leonardo
dicaprio and his frequent co-star kate
winslet
but it was hard to get the sparks flying
when her husband at the time sam
mendes was directing the movie 2008's
revolutionary road
never mind the fact that they'd start
together in titanic and having to stay
afloat in a giant tank all day long
isn't real sexy
neither is having to make out with your
co-star with her husband watching from
the director's chair
winslet recalled it was more that
neither sam nor leo seemed the slightest
bit bothered i was like
is it just me who feels a bit weird
about this you know my friend my husband
when working with tom cruise on mission
impossible 2 tandy newton recalled that
kissing tom cruise was slightly icky and
sort of wet
newton then rather bluntly stated i'd go
home at the end of the day
actually moaning she also spoke
firsthand on how difficult it is to get
romantic with a full production crew
looming over you making sure everything
is just right
you're lying there you've got 30 people
around you prodding all bits of you to
make sure that certain things aren't
being seen and others look good
newton also pointed out the pitfalls of
a kissing scene extend beyond slobbery
garlic breath
you can't kiss too hard because then
your face sort of spreads across the
other person and it looks terrible
you find that you're thinking more about
whether or not you're squashing him than
kissing him
another reason why kissing on screen
isn't authentic it's not spontaneous
cinematic kisses often have to be
planned out because of all the different
camera angles involved
it's an intricate task no matter who's
behind the camera and you certainly
won't enjoy it if you're working with
woody allen who according to helena
bottom carter was a total control freak
mapping out her love scene in the indie
comedy mighty aphrodite
in addition to being the film's director
it was alan and bottom carter who were
supposed to lock lips
as bottom carter explained allen tells
you up front the certain ways of kissing
he does not want
no exchange of liquid is permitted it
can be a bit offensive because he makes
no effort at all it's like kissing the
berlin wall
trust us kissing the berlin wall is no
great fantasy for anyone
faking romantic chemistry on screen is
incredibly tough which is why actors
make the big pucks
they can fool you into thinking they're
really into it when nothing could be
further from the truth
julia roberts had trouble being the
romantic foil to nick nolte and i love
trouble because they both hated each
other
roberts called nolte quote completely
disgusting nolte replied that roberts
was not a nice person
and they refused to do many scenes
together with stand-ins performing them
instead
roberts and nolte did indeed kiss in the
film but it was probably easier to
negotiate peace in the middle east than
to get these two together for a love
scene there were also reportedly
problems with roberts kissing her
co-star clive owen on duplicity because
she loved peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
i think you like the idea but the
biggest problem hugh grant had with
roberts when they were making notting
hill was trying to get his lips around
her mouth
as grant told andy cohen i probably made
too many jokes about the size of her
mouth she might hate me by now
brokeback mountain was a groundbreaking
film that starred jake gyllenhaal in the
late 8th ledger as two gay men who can
no longer deny their secret longing for
each other despite living in a time and
place where such a relationship will not
be tolerated
great actors can convince you of
anything but the romantic scenes between
gyllenhaal and leger were rough going to
the point where jake was injured when he
and heath tried to make out
as gylon hall recalled it heath almost
broke my nose in a kissing scene he
grabs me and slams me up against the
wall and kisses me
and then i grab him and slam him up
against the wall and i kiss him and we
were doing take after take after take
we had other scenes where we fought each
other and i wasn't hurting as badly as i
did after that one
getting back to breath issues shailene
woodley and miles teller were in this
spectacular now where building
believable on-screen romance was clearly
rough going
as teller explained i would be drinking
a gatorade right before a kissing scene
chalene would be like
are you serious you're gonna kiss me
after that i was like yeah i am
she would take these herbal supplements
and they tasted like crap and she would
always eat them right before we had a
kissing scene
okay
one time teller told woodley jay you
just ate dirt and she countered miles
you just ate licorice and so on
and as miles devilishly confirmed we put
stuff on our mouths so we could just
defend each other
it doesn't seem like this kind of
exchange would leave anybody hot and
bothered so they really looked
passionate on screen they deserve the
academy award
fans of the harry potter franchise spent
a decade watching characters like harry
potter ron weasley hermione granger and
more grow up before their eyes
of course that means the characters
respective actors grew up together
all of which made things extremely
awkward for rupert grint and emma watson
when they had to kiss in harry potter
and the deathly hallows part two
it's always gonna be quite a strange
thing i think uh kind of
kissing someone kissing a friend really
because someone i've known for kind of
ten years for her part watson said she
ended up pouncing on rupert to get it
all over with
another actor apparently in need of
altoids is ben affleck at least
according to sandra bullock
she reportedly diplomatically tried to
offer affleck breath mints when they
were making out during forces of nature
aflac also had difficulties kissing a
man in the comedy chasing amy he said
that kissing a man can be the greatest
challenge an actor can ever face
and he added that it was just difficult
for me you know and i didn't think it
would be
i really backed down from it in a way i
really could have done more of a
committed job
he even told the new york times the kiss
is in there but it looks like tom and
jerry
it's not anything good i tried to go
open mouth but something in me was take
your tongue back and i was like no
you can do it push it was not my
proudest moment
how many men have dreamed of kissing
marilyn monroe well tony curtis was one
of the lucky ones he got to make out
with marilyn in the comedy classic some
like it hot but when asked what it was
like to be intimate with such a
legendary hollywood sex symbol curtis
replied that it was like quote kissing
hitler
curtis later disavowed what he said
stating i said it as a joke
i mean it was such a darn stupid
question so i gave a stupid answer
yet making out with marilyn monroe
wasn't exactly a dream come true either
although he'd been facetious when he
compared her to one of history's most
reviled figures he went on to point out
that when the cameras rolled the kiss
was
awful she nearly choked me to death by
deliberately sticking her tongue down my
throat into my windpipe
there go the fantasies of millions of
men check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one